prudence sur les routes évinoise
l'épisode neigeux annoncé par météo
france s'intensifie pour permettre aux
véhicules de circuler sur les 200 km de
routes de la métropole de saint quentin
en yvelines
les saleuses sont en pleine action
[Musique]
puisque les routes ce sont aussi les
trottoirs qu'il faut dégager dans la
commune de montigny le bretonneux
on suit attentivement les prévisions
teintées rouge donc c'est à dire que
c'est pas bon signe mais c'est pas parce
que c'est rouge que c'est dramatique
la commune réalise une véritable veille
météorologique grâce à un logiciel très
précis jusqu'à 11 heures du matin demain
il va neiger sans cesse pour le moment
les prévisions ne sont pas si alarmante
entre 17h et minuit
il va tomber entre 1 cm et 1 cm 3 de
neige à l'heure mais comme les sols sont
très humide donc la neige
elle va pas forcément tenir les tableaux
accompagnés des images radars permettent
à la ville d'anticiper hilare après midi
les abords des crèches et des écoles ont
été préparés toutes les équipes du
service technique sont mobilisés depuis
7h ce matin opération salage 90 tonnes
de sel sont en stock des réserves qui
sont les mêmes depuis deux ans j'ai cinq
personnes a dû madame des petits engins
motorisés
et sinon on est s12 équipe de 3
personnes sur toute la commune pour
resaler tout ce qui est écoles crèches
dégager les passages piétons dégager les
arrêts de bus et dégage est toujours le
même au moins un trottoir sur de
l'opération se poursuit demain pour les
différents services techniques de
l'agglomération et avant que tous soient
déneigées
certains comptent bien en profiter